Katharina Willinger ist im
Erdbebengebiet und zwar im türkischen
adija man Frau Willinger wie ist aktuell
bei Ihnen vor Ort die Situation
ja man gehört tatsächlich zu den am
schlimmsten getroffenen Städten in der
gesamten Region offiziell liegen die
Zahl der Toten bei etwa 800 aber die
Anwohner hier gehen davon aus dass es in
die Tausende gehen wird die Situation
ist wirklich dramatisch man kann
vielleicht hinter mir auch sehen ich
stehe vor einem der vielen vielen
eingestürzten Mehrfamilienhäuser
teilweise auch Hochhäuser hier laufen
die Bergungsarbeiten noch es ist eiskalt
die Temperaturen liegen bei minus fünf
Grad momentan und das hinter mir sind
vor allen Dingen freiwillige Helfer
teilweise von Baufirmen teilweise aus
einer benachbarten Ölfirma hier
angereist die sich mit Baumaterial mit
Hilfsmaterialien Werkzeugen zu behelfen
wissen es mangelt hier in der Stadt
tatsächlich an professionellen Einsatz
Teams bisher das heißt die Bergung der
Menschen schreitet sehr sehr schleppen
voran und natürlich schwindet auch mit
jeder Minute mit jeder Stunde die
Hoffnung überhaupt noch Überlebende zu
finden
wie läuft denn die Versorgung der
Menschen die nicht mehr in ihre Häuser
zurück können wo schlafen die denn vor
Ort
also wir waren ja heute den ganzen Tag
über unterwegs in der Erdbebenregion und
haben mit mehreren Menschen darüber
gesprochen was sie denn eigentlich wo
sie jetzt ausharren wo sie jetzt sich
aufwärmen und viele haben gesagt wir
waren in unseren Autos in der Nacht
manche waren draußen manche haben
irgendwie zu sucht in in Werkstätten die
jetzt nicht in diesem unmittelbaren
erdbebenzentrum gelegen haben es gibt
natürlich auch Städte da wurden Zelte
errichtet da sind auch ähm der türkische
Rote Halbmond beispielsweise im Einsatz
aber hier jetzt den Adler Mann sehen wir
momentan da wo wir stehen das ist eine
der großen Hauptstrassen wenig
Einsatzkräfte von staatlicher Seite
viele private Organisationen die hier
rumfahren teilweise einfach nur in LKWs
oder einen kleinen Minibussen und
schreien dann quasi runter wer braucht
hilfe wer braucht Essen wer braucht Tee
halten kurz anbringen was und fahren
dann weiter es ist ja Tag zwei erst nach
dieser fürchterlichen
erdbebenkatastr ich hoffe ich glaube wir
sind jetzt bei gezählten 7000 Toten und
es hieß ja gestern dass eventuell
Nachbeben zu erwarten zu befürchten ist
sind wie groß ist denn die Angst der
Menschen vor weiteren Nachbeben
ja tatsächlich ist diese Angst sehr groß
weil es wurden mittlerweile mehr als 200
Nachbeben gezählt gestern gab es ja auch
noch mal starke nachgeben ich glaube
Experten haben das dritte große Beben
gar nicht als Nachbeben bezeichnet
sondern als eigenständiges Erdbeben es
hatte ja noch mal die Stärke 7,5 als wir
heute in die aber Kiel gelandet sind das
liegt etwa zweieinhalb Stunden entfernt
von adiamant da sind wir am Flughafen
angekommen und es hat direkt gewackelt
zwar nur leicht aber diese kleinen
nachgeben die versetzen die Menschen
natürlich in Angst und Schrecken denn
viele Häuser die jetzt nicht eingestürzt
sind die sind ja auch beschädigt wir
haben sehr viele große lange Risse in
den Wänden gesehen und natürlich haben
die Menschen Angst da jetzt reinzugehen
und dazu übernachten und auch Gefahr zu
laufen dass diese Gebäude vielleicht
tatsächlich noch in den nächsten Tagen
oder Wochen einstürzen Frau Willinger es
gibt ja viele internationale
Hilfsangebote offenbar sind ja die
internationalen Helfer bei ihnen
jedenfalls vor Ort noch nicht
eingetroffen was würden Sie denn nach
den Erfahrungen vor Ort sagen was ist
die Dr Erste Hilfe der internationalen
Gemeinschaft die jetzt notwendig ist
also von meinem Standort aus hier kann
ich definitiv sagen professionelle
Einsatzkräfte
professionelle jetzt wird uns hier
gerade was Angeboten zu trinken und zu
essen sie kümmern sich auch um uns als
Presse es fehlt vor allen Dingen an
professionellen Einsatzkräften und an
Hilfsmaterialien also wie gesagt hinter
mir
da behelfen sich die Menschen mit Sachen
die sie selbst mitgebracht haben
teilweise eben mit Werkzeugen einer hat
sich hier hinter uns sein Bagger
geliehen von einem Bauunternehmer aber
es gibt keine Suchhunde es gibt
beispielsweise keine Abhörgeräte das
mangelt also an diesen Dingen und das
wird natürlich händeringend gebraucht
Katharina Willinger war das aus der
Türkei vielen Dank für diese
Erläuterungen und danke für Ihre Zeit